got to welcome on one of the most
underrated db's in the nfl period all
pro cornerback chris harris jr chris
thanks for coming on man we really
appreciate this do you have a new head
coach out there in brandon staley how
many conversations have you had with him
what's what's what's the dialogue so far
what are y'all thinking
oh man it's been great just being able
to uh talk to him i talked to him once
but he's a guy i talked to a lot in the
past uh playing being one of his
teammates you know as he was assigned
linebacker coach in denver but i kind of
know how to pick his brand he picks my
brain he's a very smart coach
i'm very i was surprised to see how fast
he rose but he took it to another level
with the rams and i always knew he was
capable of being a great new coordinator
you have a young quarterback out there
too who just seems like he's getting
better and better from your perspective
give me your read on herbert
yeah
man herbert got all the tools in the
world to be great in this league and a
great attitude great fundamentals and
just got to continue to learn the game
continue to
uh
be able to put the offense in the best
situations to win and that comes with
growth and i think he's going to take
that next level next year and continue
to uh be a great quarterback
you played against both brady and
mahomes i'm gonna start with brady let
me start with my homes first what is the
key to slowing them down we know you
can't stop them but what what is the key
to slowing them down
yeah
man my home she's just he can get out
that pocket and that's the thing uh
people forget that he he almost throws
more yards outside the pocket than he
does inside the pocket so you got to be
able to have a great rush um lanes
uh great
coverage and rush together
um that's and that's the best thing you
can do man he has so many weapons that
eventually he's gonna find somebody to
get open but you can play tight reds on
defense knowing that they're gonna get
their yards
but play great defense in the red zone
that'll give you a chance
well you talk about all the weapons that
they have and to me
i know tyreek hill gets a lot of
attention but to me it's almost like um
travis kelsey is that guy because he
kind of opens up everything on the
outside because he you know he rules the
middle
who's the most dangerous if you're a
defensive coordinator you're todd bowles
who are you going in and saying this is
the number one guy we have to stop
oh uh tyra kill hands down
make the uh big play
open the game up real fast and i mean no
tiger he opens it up for kelsey it's
about somebody you know
kelsey uh gets to run routes and get
opening a little zone
tyrique is taking everybody off taking
the top off you know
and uh so that's more of a threat when
you when you look at this game
and i have one i have one more for you
real quick and i was just telling jack
and i i know you watched this on tape
have you guys had discussions about
jamming and slowing these guys down
because when you watch them on tape
every every corner just opens up the
gate and let him run his 4-2 right down
the field do you guys have candid
conversations about jamming and being
physical with these guys
oh yeah definitely that's something that
you can try to do
um tiger hill i mean he's one of the
quickest guys off the ball you know what
i mean he releases now too so when he
first got in the league that was this
thing he couldn't get off the gym too
good so now he's gotten stronger he's
came into his body and now he can get
off the gym easy so uh it's it's easier
said than done for sure
no doubt no doubt jack chris who do you
think when you look at this game it's
like two all-star teams on offense right
who do you think wins like how do you
think this game plays out walk me
through it
yeah
uh man i'm always gonna go with the
quarterback that can run i don't think
in this day and age it's gonna be hard
to win a super bowl if you can't run as
a quarterback so i'm always gonna go
with the quarterback that can run and
throw so i gotta ride with my homes for
sure
but brady and them have all the weapons
uh he knows what it takes to win the
super bowl he knows what it takes
um to to not ever be out in the game he
can come back anytime in the game so uh
brady has that experience
and he still does have weapons
i guess my question to you is
go ahead rob i'm sorry
we've watched the charges for years and
we've always seen the mistakes and the
penalties and just just bad football and
those critical moments
what will it take to get you guys
because you've always had great talent
like what will it take to get you guys
to that next level
yeah
uh i think just everybody learn how to
finish games you know that's something
as a team you have to learn how to do
and as we as we finished the season
strong we started continuing to learn we
started doing that and building that
camaraderie and knowing how to finish
gangs and that was our issue that was
always been our issue when i played the
the chargers we knew that uh it's going
we we usually finish the games better
than what they do so that's something
that uh we gotta we tried to fix last
year
uh i think at the end of the year we
started working on fixing that and
hopefully we can keep that keep that
going this year
yeah i i think it's interesting that you
took you you went straight for casey and
it's everyone's kind of knee-jerk
reactions like yeah mahomes like this
offense they're just gonna score more
points so you can't stop them the
significance of having two great tackles
out though fisher and schwartz both of
them missing this game how do you read
that
oh that means jack baird and uh jpp so
you have some uh
they should have a couple snacks man
the pressure should be there from the
books so we know that they're going to
bring the pressure but the stage you
still got to be able to get my homes
just because uh the pressure's coming
you still got to be able to tackle them
and he can still throw it with
guys on them and twist it up so you got
to get that man down so
uh but hopefully shaq barrett and jpp do
their thing because it's going to be
crucial for the uh rush to get there
hey chris when you when you kind of
growing up man who was your guy in the
backyard that you pretended to be i mean
like
you know was it an offensive player was
it a defensive player like who was your
guy who did you pretend to be when you
were a kid growing up
man my favorite corners growing up was
uh aeneas williams
he was a guy i loved his attitude the
way he played the ball the way he played
all over the field
um ty law
uh i love ty law's smartness just the
way he always attacked the rock he was
always in a great place a great position
to make plays
and uh champ bailey of course my mentor
so i got to always rock with champ a guy
that i always looked up to
coming into the league
but uh those first two guys man when i
was younger and mia's williams ty law
man i love those two
you know it's funny because we used to
practice against arizona um they used to
fly out to san diego and stay a few days
with us and aeneas williams would always
be out there an hour early and as soon
as everyone walked out he was drenched
in sweat he had an hours workout before
anyone got out there he was a very
spiritual man he was a very disciplined
man and he loved his technique and
that's one of the things that i see when
i see you
you really focus on technique and to me
that's what's why you've been so good
for such a long time talk about you know
kind of your natural instincts and what
you do out there on the football field
man with me it comes like like me it's
like how he came out there's your
preparation man it's how you prepared uh
i feel like um playing 11 years or going
into my 11th season
i've always tried to make plays with my
brains first you know what i mean make
it make the play happen quicker for me
on the field and i've always had great
quickness great lateral quickness
uh being able to play all over the field
and really man it's just my smarts that
kind of set me up set me apart from a
lot of the guys in this
hey league we really appreciate you
jumping on man all pro cornerbacks been
so great watching you play great watch
you play denver great watching you play
now in la this young team looks like you
guys really may turn into something so
continue to lead them man thanks for
joining us
all the best chris appreciate you gotta
do it again man we gotta do it again
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports